All right, this is on how to negotiate or the art of deal-making,
whether you like it or not, you are a salesperson.
You're going to be persuading others to buy into your ideas, your services,
your product, your career path,
investing in you in some capacity, you need to learn how to persuade.
So we'll talk about a few different techniques that I use routinely for
negotiating, which isn't exactly the same as persuasion.
If you're interested in the general broad scope of persuasion and influence,
I highly recommend you pick up the book influence by Robert Cialdini or
Cialdini. I'm not sure how it is pronounced,
but that is a classic that I read many,
many times at the very beginning of my career and found very, very helpful.
Getting into negotiating a few things to keep in mind, mantra.
Number one is he or she who cares the least wins.
So having options is very helpful for giving you that type of confidence,
walkaway power. The other is doing an exercise called fear setting so that the
downsides of losing the negotiation are D tooth in
a way.
And you can find out more about fear setting@tim.blog Ford slash Ted had an
entire Ted talk on this. So I won't spend time on it right now,
a few things when it comes to negotiating a price, a deal structuring,
et cetera, the first is that you want the counterparty,
the person that you're negotiating with to negotiate against themselves first,
how do you do that? If possible? I like to ask them to make the first offer,
put something on the table to get the ball rolling,
or to initiate the conversation.
And very often you'll be interacting with someone who you can position as the
expert. You know, more about this than I do. You've done this a hundred times.
This is my first rodeo.
Why don't you just put something on the table so that we can discuss it as a
starting point?
That is in my experience very often more beneficial than it is
harmful. Sometimes they will try to anchor that is giving you a very,
very high ball price or a very, very low ball price,
depending on if they're on the sell side or the buy side.
But generally speaking,
I like to get the other side to open up and show their initial hand.
At that point you can do, what's called a flinch.
And when I lived in China and Beijing in 96,
I saw this all the time where you'd go to buy a shirt or a phone
charger or whatever it might be,
and you would offer a price and then the woman selling it would go
and make all these faces and contortions. And so on.
She did that very deliberately to get me to then back off or retract or
backstep right.
You don't have to make some type of extreme theatrical to accomplish this.
You could just pause and go. Hmm. You know, that's,
that's a bit more than I would have expected and then wait.
And the waiting is the hardest.
So if you can develop the ability to sit in silence,
you will have a tremendous advantage in negotiating.
So you want to flinch in some fashion first. Wow.
That's a lot higher than I would have expected then perhaps they backpedal,
which happens a lot, especially with novice or intermediate negotiators.
And then you can very simply ask, is that the best that you can do?
Do you think this is the best that you guys can offer? And again,
pause and wait, when you want to get into some of the more, I suppose,
fisticuffs or develop techniques in negotiating different types of bracketing,
how to make certain concessions,
how to drill into what they want the needs behind their requests.
So they want a certain price, but what are the incentives?
Are they trying to hit a quota? Do they want to, for instance,
be remembered in some fashion or retain branding,
maybe a statue in front of the shopping center would do instead of them getting
top dollar on the shopping center, you're trying to buy something like that.
There are resources that can help with these types of more advanced techniques.
Uh, one would be Roger Dawson, secrets of power negotiating.
I listened to that in audio format. It is available in audio.
I don't know the quality these days,
but I listened to that driving to and from work during my commute in
2000, 2001. And if I remember correctly,
Roger made his first fortune in real estate.
And I found it very, very helpful. And particularly only in audio.
So I could hear it inflection, how he delivered certain phrases,
asked certain questions. The other book is getting past no,
and the author, or at least coauthors William Ury,
U R Y getting past no was a follow-up to getting
to yes,
which was a book co-authored by the founders of the Harvard negotiation project.
I believe it is one of which is William Ury,
but getting past no is I think the more pragmatic,
realistic way to phrase many of your experiences in the world of
negotiating,
you're going to be either trying to sell something that isn't immediately
obvious to someone,
or you're going to be trying to buy something at a price or with a structure
that isn't immediately obviously appealing to someone.
Otherwise it's not negotiating.
You simply put something on the table and you sell it or you buy it.
The other facet of negotiating is avoiding it altogether.
And that sort of leads to this,
which is you can structure your life to avoid certain types of negotiation.
In the case of say my podcast and podcast sponsorship of a very lean team of
just a few people,
and we want to avoid altogether the extreme back and forth that can be involved
with ad purchasing or selling.
This is very routine and podcasts size of mine very often have staff of 20,
30 people and agencies and all sorts of folks involved to avoid that.
We decided that we would have everyone pre-pay. There are no payment terms,
no net 30 or anything like that. We did not offer any discounts,
still don't offer any discounts. And we would charge a premium.
The way you get a discount is by locking in today's pricing.
Because with the rate of growth we expected with the podcast,
the absolute pricing would always go up, not the CPM.
And so there are ways that you can set policies and systems in place in the
beginning so that you do not have to expend many,
many cycles of negotiating to pull that off, though, in the case of the podcast,
you have to deliver very, very high amounts of traffic with high conversion,
right? So that in a sense, forces you to deliver a higher quality product.
And I always find that the premium space or selling to the affluent,
if you want to take a look at that book to be much,
much easier than negotiating with players who are looking for the
lowest cost option.
So those are a few approaches to deal making and negotiating and
structuring different approaches to putting together,
say packages for buying or selling that I found useful.
And I hope you do as well.